[Music]
hello there we are now seven weeks deep
into fortnite season eight the cubed
season which brought back kevin but
that's only the tip of this iceberg when
it comes to map updates and story
secrets today we're looking for
underwater gnomes the opening of the
bunker and the flossing mushroom it's a
weird update my creator code is adam
marrow if you'd be so kind and if not
just sit your butt down for five minutes
and let's find the changes on the island
it finally happened after two years 10
days and 18 hours of waiting the
redacted bunker we saw on day one of the
chapter is no longer a mystery as of
today it is confirmed as an io facility
a mountain base i won't lie inside i'm a
little underwhelmed by this place it's
super tiny and very minimal but no
frowns here this could be the beginning
of the greatest storyline in fortnite
history sloan spent seven weeks
gathering the remains of the alien
mothership flanked by io troops and
slowly took them here i've been trying
my best to figure out why this spot and
it's likely that after the underground
base under the farm was destroyed last
season the only place untouched was the
mountain bunker and potentially this is
sloan's last stand sloan hasn't rested
for a second and has already moved the
load from the truck outside onto these
two platforms i don't know much about
this i presume this is some sort of
analysis tech either finding a weakness
in the alien vessel or maybe using it to
create a weapon against the queen or it
could just be a way to bring back the
brute mechs to make twitch dreamers cry
from the brute a new two-player vehicle
that packs some serious firepower i'm
not playing anymore bro i'm off this
game
we have no answers right now but at
least we can throw out some old theories
remember these ones like the time we
thought chaos agent was in here building
a sludge army good memories all that the
giant mech which flew into space was
being kept here ready for round two with
the polar peak monster aka your mum the
only one with answers is sloan and i
still can't understand the word she says
i'll lay on me
this week i highly recommend you visit
the old mill many people have noticed
that madcap calls this place home and
over the past few updates the mould from
his presence has caused the inside of
this building to become a little bit
gross that is totally forgivable thanks
to these little critters
how cute are these things dancing near
them brings them to life and if you're
lucky they'll even floss for you
[Music]
they are indestructible right now i try
to burn them ax them shoot them my boys
are only here for good times just two
fun guys sat in a corner not taking up
mushroom there's actually a homage to
chapter one right here in this building
between the twins this moldy yellow mess
was originally an object with no hitbox
meaning it couldn't be destroyed and
worse still we could walk inside it and
hide there this led to a strap being
used to hide inside that yellow mushroom
and bait players towards it for very
easy eliminations this became such a big
issue that huge streamers like lachlan
made it mainstream epic were forced to
resize those shrooms to stop the meme in
its tracks the one right now in the game
by madcap is full size but alas we can't
hide inside this it's a solid object
good to see the asset came back without
being shrunk again
oh no he found me
on to the real story of season eight and
chapter two overall that of the gnomes
in the same time sloane has taken to
walk her bony butt over to the bunker
the gnomes have devised a plan to break
their brothers out of jail made a daring
escape across the wolf-filled
countryside to a set of waiting boats at
the river these guys are trained and
professional well i thought that until
today because they are now at the foot
of the dam strewn everywhere seemingly
they've sailed straight off the end here
i think they're all accounted for some
of them are doing much better than the
others one remains trapped inside the
boat another is completely submerged on
the water waiting for help this chap is
stuck headfirst and needs rescuing and
this one is my spirit animal he's just
give up my kind of guy what could the
endgame be for these dudes is it to
escape the island or a better scheme
would be to create a new colony just for
gnomes i kind of hope they are heading
to aurelia's island it's secluded nobody
lands there anymore and a safe place to
build a gnome haven if that is the plan
we should tell the other gnomes around
the island who remain frozen in place
about to board boats to escape up at
craggy cliffs they are moments away from
setting sail same with those over at
holly hedges including the really cool
guy who just lays down all the time the
story continues in the next update oh
this may be nothing but here at the damn
turbines is a secret home of another
gnome the golden toilet gnome we checked
on him regularly in the past and nothing
has ever changed so i stopped talking
about him but this season i was told
that the burning candles inside have
turned black like i say this could be
something it could be nothing but i
think it's worth pointing out that no
gnome has ventured in here yet could
those washed up gnomes outside be the
ones to awaken this dude
i just realized i'm a grown man talking
about a gnome in a golden toilet life
goals
there's a few changes to be aware of
this week the first is at the
convergence as the cube town is growing
it's so generically random here that
it's tough to actually see the changes
but this place is definitely updating
from now on as the queen continues to do
whatever she's doing in that bubble
looks like a rubik's cube to me i'll
keep an eye on this place and document
all the changes and let you know next
time this place is going to be important
soon hopefully this update i was
expecting the music stage we saw on the
halloween fortnite ads to be a real
thing but alas still no stage and no
ariana concert version 2. the map
continues to update the island is now
covered in halloween gobbings almost all
residents in all pli's are in the mood
for halloween but still no stage do you
reckon it'll come and that reminds me
there is a musical update this time
around have you heard the music pack
sang by the queen herself i'm not sure
if it's copper written content so i'm
not going to cover it in this video but
the lyrics reveal a lot about the lore
of the island and she sings about the
seven too
[Music]
so let's put a pin in that for now but
we definitely will revisit that and
finally the tiny chair looks to have had
its final ever update today the bear the
chair the telescope are all now 100
the right size after months and months
of shrinking and then regrowth it's been
emotional random chair on a hill there
is potential that this isn't the end and
maybe these things will grow to a
hulking great monstrosity imagine
finding a 20-foot chair with a 30-foot
bear on top now that is a poi hang on a
second the telescope is now completely
indestructible maybe this isn't the end
after all i guess we keep watching
[Music]
rightio i've gotta go i've gotta go get
that new batman foundation comic book
and start my breakdown that video should
be out in a day or two i'm running
criminally low on batman memes and
stupid references so if you know any
please send me a dm on twitter or just
at me somewhere i'm sure i'll find you
thank you very much for your time it's
much appreciated as always on screen now
are some legends who slid into my dms
this week using code adamarrow in the
store thank you very much for rocking my
code it is really appreciated i'm adam
you're awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]
you